if you're somebody's into pizza if
you're somebody's into spicy food both
of these pizzas smack but
when I'm in this chair I have to Crown a
winner and I do have a winner my
favorite of the pizzas was
[Music]
as the host of first we feed hot ones
Sean Evans has faced off against
Carolina Reapers going Toe to Toe with
pepper X and devoured more than 2 000
scorching hot chicken wings it's tough
to make this guy break a sweat but what
happens when you harness the power of
spice and combine it with one of Sean's
favorite foods on the planet
today I'm setting out on a mission to
create the ultimate spicy pizza for Sean
one that cranks up the heat but also
tastes delicious my Challenger today is
chef Mike Carter from down North Pizza
in Philadelphia Pennsylvania down North
is an amazing mission-based Pizzeria
owned and operated by the formerly
incarcerated and their spicy Detroit
style pies have become a huge hit in the
City of Brotherly Love Can Mike and I
come up with pizza spicy enough to make
Sean feel the burn there's only one way
to find out
today we've got Mike Carter in the
building from down North Pizza we are
thrilled to have you here on Pizza Wars
how you doing today I'm a great Nicole
thank you for having me westfully up
when I heard about you guys I thought
what you guys were doing was so amazing
why don't you tell the folks at home all
about your business down North pizzas
and the hardest Strawberry Mansion
section of North Philly we do Detroit
style pizza with Philly influence
because it wouldn't be what it is if it
didn't have all that Philly flavor and
our mission is to combat recidivism so
we set out to be the Catalyst and be the
change that we want to see in our
neighborhoods so you
can call it reverse discrimination but
like I'm not trying to hear that noise
like it's like we hiring people that are
from the same background and we're
giving them the second chance that they
deserve I'm with
witty Mike it's all
what makes a good spicy Pizza balance
because uh sometimes like you may eat
something that's too hot and I may like
it yeah I mean but somebody else they
knock it down just because maybe it
wasn't enough fat to combat the spice
it's all about marriage so today we're
gonna make some pieces of the crazy
spicy but also crazy delicious and I
can't wait to see what you got going on
so today I have my sauce it up pizza is
a smoked chicken Thai curry pizza at
down North we doing Square pods slinging
pods and saving lives and we start off
with the square dough and our four
cheese blend so it's mozzarella low
moisture mats provolone and cheddar this
chicken right here I massaged it oh with
this excuse me and then I Let It Rock
out at 165 in the sous vide I got the
grill started glue the chicken thighs on
there and I'll let it go you're
describing this pizza makes me want to
faint
I'm like and then what happened
so uh from here I'm gonna throw it in
the oven and I'm gonna finish it off
with the garnish okay it looks pretty
thank you so much so into the oven we go
all right I think it's done time to see
what we doing let's go
oh there it goes looking good nice and
cheesy as far as like Detroit pies go
the edge they call it the crown well
since we're combating recidivism at down
North Pizza we like to call it the
cheese fence the crispiness of it it
makes the perfect crust so I cut it into
my six slices right and now it's time to
put the toppings on top yes so a healthy
squeeze of this red curry sauce right
there and this is my hot sauce blend so
I pickled up some bird chilies a little
ginger a couple other things okay and of
course we need these accoutrements right
here get these onions all over the pizza
and these are some pickled carrots and
then we're going to finish it off with a
couple of these pickled peppers I'm just
gonna clap for you is wonderful thank
you so much but let's get into this I'm
ready for my slice you ready for your
slice let's go okay well cheers
there you go
[Music]
oh man the heat is hitting me now
you still gonna need a little bit more
no it's spicy
it's definitely spicy everybody needs a
little bit of spicy ain't like that the
dough is nice and pillowy the dough is
actually help me cool down my mouth
because you have enough dough where it
can just take away some of that Heat
against your balance approval yeah no
like it's hot you know it's hot
but it's flavorful I love it no doubt
thank you sis well you did a phenomenal
job knocked it out the park are you
ready to see what I'm gonna do yeah
let's get it all right
[Music]
all right Mike so today what I am making
is a Nashville chicken pizza have you
ever had natural chicken yeah I love it
you do I love it oh my God this is right
up my alley then all right I hope you
really like mine so first things first
is I'm using my good old trusty New York
dough that's been fermenting for two
days so when I did last dragon Pizza I
was known for my hot marinara so that's
my marinara nice healthy amount then
we're going to take our 50 50 blend part
skin part whole milk mozzarella a little
garlic powder
and then now I'm gonna put this in the
oven
just came out of the oven and now it's
time to dress it so first things first
is I'm gonna put some onions down and
then it is natural hot chicken so I'm
gonna put some pickles down bread and
butter pickles I'm using and then we're
gonna take this beautiful chicken here
and I'm just gonna toss it in this
Nashville hot sauce we put some brown
sugar cayenne pepper and it'll just
bring a little extra heat we put a
little scorpion pepper in the oil what
do you think so far I love natural hot
chicken like I played with the idea
before but I think Nicole is taking me
to school on how to do it and just put a
little extra heat and just going to toss
a little red peppers all over that and
then finally I'm just gonna drop some
dill I always think dill and fried
chicken just go so well together that's
it what do you think sexy
I'm glad we want to make sexy pizza
ready yeah I'm ready
um
it's a creeper oh it's hot it's Slam
Dancing
that's Nashville hot chicken for you
you know the judge is Sean Evans he's
used to this heat I'm not I mean I like
a little heat but this is a lot of heat
there's some milk or something
man I'm loving everything that you did
here from the crust we got going on with
the dough that's like the most important
thing you know when you're making a
piece of the the infrastructure and then
what you did with this chicken it is so
delicious bread and butter pickles I
think they actually bought like that
sweet kicked with it and those herbs at
the end that Dill if I'll get a natural
hot sandwich I wanted this taste like
this pizza oh thank you so much well
Mike your pizza was phenomenal I feel
like I did my thing as well but we've
got the one and only perfect judge for
this challenge Sean Evans from hot ones
part of the first week Feast family was
so happy to have him in the building and
he's going to try both of our pieces are
you ready yes let's get ready to run
let's go let's go
so when I come to Pizza Wars I'm pretty
simple you know they're both gonna make
amazing pizzas I already know that so I
think what's gonna push a pizza over the
finish line or over the goal line for me
is going to be the way that they
incorporate spice how does it elevate
the pizza and then the creative ways
that they do it is it tasty how is spice
infused is it clever is it creative and
is it worth breaking a sweat for all
right so I'm about to try the First
Slice
[Music]
Mmm delicious pizza Amazing Pizza I'm
not sure I was expecting any spice when
I first bit it I didn't really taste it
up front then after you swallow it
leaves like kind of like a aromatic
spicy trail behind it that has now kind
of lit up my whole mouth and has my eyes
watering a little bit so a solid like
6.5 I would say on heat and then up
there close to a 10 on taste on a
constructive criticism level it's maybe
a little bready it's got some muffin on
it it's got a little muffin on it all
right
bring in the next Pizza we have our
second pizza and I have to say it's a
beautiful Pizza all right I'm gonna Dive
In
Blown Away by the pizza
Blown Away a little bit by the heat too
I would say it's coming in a way that I
am reminded of being on the show Almost
also for me I've eaten so much chicken
that like the wings I don't really eat
it in my free time because I'm so burnt
out on it so the chicken has to smack
for me to just go in and seek it out and
that's our mat with this pizzas I'm
seeking out the chicken it's so good all
right so I've tried my pizzas I have my
winner filed away it's now time to bring
out Mike bring out Nicole and Crown a
winner
[Music]
Sean I'm so happy you're back welcome
back thanks so much for having me we
couldn't have done this with anybody
else but you well I appreciate you
having me on your show because you
always feed me so well you know both of
these pizzas were so good so thanks for
having me no problem we can't take it
any longer we worked very hard on our
pies tell us what you thought of both of
them all right so first off I love both
of them there are no losers today it is
just winners because both of these
pizzas if you're somebody's into pizza
if you're somebody's into spicy food
both of these pizzas smack I first tried
this Detroit style pizza and I knew that
would be amazing right off the bat
because it has that perfect Detroit
style crust what I really loved about it
from a spice perspective is it kind of
left like a spice Trail now on over to
the Nashville style fried chicken the
way that it was cooked I thought was
great I was telling people earlier it's
tough for me to get back into chicken
because I eat so much chicken I eat so
much hot sauce when I'm off the clock
that chicken has to be so good for me to
be into it and this chicken and was so
good I thought it was just kind of a
perfect pie in so many ways so both
pizzas
amazing but
when I'm in this chair I have to Crown a
winner and I do have a winner on this
challenge my favorite of the pizzas was
the national style fried chicken
congratulations thank you but no
congratulations to you I never do this
Mike I never do this but all the good
work you're doing I'm gonna forfeit my
win today you are the winner because
you're a winner in real life thank you
I never do that I never do this
you're the winner I love everything
you're doing I wish you much success
thank you so much for being a part of
our show thanks for having me on the
call like it was an awesome experience
being up here chopping up with you in
the back in the green room that's right
yeah you're such a dope person and
thanks for having me on here my pleasure
see you next time on pizza wars
[Music]